[music]
Mojo. Good afternoon, ladies and
gentlemen. My name is David Beachch. I
am the principal of Cresmon Investments,
a private equity firm based in New York
City. We structure direct investments
into businesses serving energy,
healthcare, and industrial sectors. and
over the past several years have become
convinced that physical AI represents
one of the most important investment
themes of the next decade. So I'm
honored to be joined by two business
leaders who bring complimentary
perspectives
as builders and users
for uh with Sophocles Zulas founder
chairman and CEO of Zenith Shipping who
spent decades leading one of the world's
premier shipping companies and Dr.
Nicholas Radford, uh, one of the
pioneers of industrial humanoid robotics
and CEO of Persona AI.
So, gentlemen, we'll jump right in. So,
let's see.
So, we have three questions today. We'll
go through and let the conversation go.
So for our first question, given your
collective experience in ship building,
energy and infrastructure, why do you
think that these industries will become
major adopters of physical AI? I'll let
you start first off.
>> I'll take that. Can everyone hear me?
>> Okay, he can hear me. You can hear me.
So um we want to do something a little
different for everyone here today. I
don't build robots. I'm not a tech
person. I have spent almost 40 years in
heavy industry,
specifically shipping in an industry
that moves 90%
of the world's goods every day.
And for 20 years, as a user, as as
someone who needs this technology, we've
had labor shortages, inefficient
logistics. I mean, you see what's
happened just with the Straits of
Hormuz. Things that disrupt my world
disrupt the entire world. And I see
physical AI as the the hinge point that
my industry's been waiting for for 20
years. And I think the moment is is now.
And we will get into the details uh in
this chat.
>> I think I think mainly because the
numbers are just staggering. Um
there's a there's there seems to be like
a controversial bifurcation in the
embodied AI space specifically around
humanoids. Uh one from the platform
perspective and that's a whole another
we can go have a beer and debate that
and it's a fun debate to have but it's
whether these robots are going to be
adopted first in domestic use cases that
might look like the home folding laundry
serving coffee or are they going to be
adopted more in the industrial segments.
Um if you look at if you look at the
numbers there's about 3.5 billion
workers on the planet about one in four
of them are in the infrastructure
industrial complex. Think everything
that made this building to the goods
that Sophocles was talking about being
shipped around the world to the energy
that's pumped out of the ground to the
cars that are made. That's a billion
workers. So let's say they work 2,000
hours a year. That is do the math a
trillion I think that's right right no
two trillion two trillion hours two
trillion hours of industrial labor so
let's say that uh let's say we're
building some automation technology like
a humanoid we can capture 1%
no investor typically wants you to
capture 1% of a market but here it might
be okay 1% of that market is 20 billion
hours if we assume that there's a $50
loaded cost $50 per hour loaded cost
that is a trillion dollars, guys. A
trillion dollars of revenue per year
capturing 1% of the industrial energy
complex. The the math is just insane.
So, I know we want to put one robot in
every home, and that sounds really
compelling, but we're talking like $2 an
hour. We're thinking that we might be
able to put a a robot into the home.
That that the arbitrage in the
industrial segments versus the home, it
doesn't even make any sense. It's like
you would go industrials all day long
>> if I if I because it is World Cup soccer
or football. Sorry.
>> Can we avoid the game for the US?
>> I'm going to bring it I'm going to bring
it into I'm going to bring it into
industry. So right now today there are
2,800 ships on order that frankly have a
three-year backlog
because there are not enough people to
meet the needs of the world. Okay. And
if we were to line up football fields
one after the other, that's the
equivalent of 10,000 football fields of
welding that needs to be done today with
the current three-year orders. 10,000
football fields that there are not
enough. We have a declining workforce
and an increasing need. This is not a
nice to have problem everyone. This is a
survival that we need to do to meet the
economic demands of the world for the
next 50 years.
>> That's just one
>> that's just one example.
>> That's just one example
>> and and the world's economies are
replete with that example over and over.
>> So speaking to that point, let's talk
about the difference between industrial
needs, declining labor, uh yet the
ongoing demand for industrial
applications, ship building in
particular. uh just spend a minute on
that before we move on to the next
question.
>> I think it's we all talk about the labor
scarcity problem, right? I mean it's
there's not a good embodied AI pitch out
there that doesn't propose to the
investors uh the declining workforce.
But if you really dig into the numbers,
it's so much worse than that. So the
world's population is probably going to
hit about 9 billion people before it
peels over and starts to be in decline.
We're not really sure where it's going
to come down to, but we already know
replacement rates in countries are are
are are not where it needs to be to
sustain the current levels of
population. So, we're looking at uh in
the next 25 years about So, today
there's one in 11 people in the world
over the age of 65. In the next 25
years, that worldwide average is going
to be one in six. It's going to be one
in four in the US. It's going to be one
in three in Europe. It's going to be one
in three in Korea. It's going to be one
in three in Japan.
So the problem that we have is that we
have a massively aging society. The
numbers are already set in stone. We
couldn't change it if we wanted to.
That's it's a fat company. So we have a
massively aging society. Plus we have
the nature of work is changing. We all
want to be YouTubers and influencers. We
don't want to be welders. Right? So now
you have this crashing problem of the
demographics that are collapsing and the
nature of work has changed. But we all
like to have conferences in these
buildings. We like to have goods shipped
across the sea. All the clothes that
everybody is wearing came on those ships
and there's not going to be anybody to
sustain it. That is the existential
crisis we're really looking at.
>> I if I could just from a like real
>> this is a really happy presentation. I I
understand that solution.
>> There's depressing. It's depressing with
a happy ending. Okay. So from a use case
perspective,
we cannot order ships that we need today
because the shipyards say, "Sorry, we
don't have the labor." That's my
problem. That's not this conference.
That's a reality that I'm facing running
my business today. And not only that, I
think what I hear in the social
narrative is, "Oh, but humanoids or
robots are displacing human labor. the
social cost of automation well in heavy
industry heavy industry is begging for
this solution. I can't talk about the
auto uh factory floor or I can't talk
about other markets but in heavy
industry mining energy global
transportation infrastructure by the way
infrastructure is about 50 years old and
that needs huge capex dangerous I think
a perfect home for for this solution
here
>> we move on to the next question so just
to summarize industrial
capex is massive, demand is increasing
and labor shortage is real. So, so what
has changed to make uh physical AI more
commercially viable today versus a few
years ago, 10 years ago? What makes it
work now?
>> There's been there's been some
appreciable tipping points. So, a a
market typically moves on three major
factors. You have a technology tipping
point, you have a social tipping point,
you have an economic tipping point. And
so if we unpack those three things, we
can we can try to understand why this
market's moving now. Technologically,
which is what everyone's focused on,
it's hard to walk around and not be uh
aed, frankly, by the advancements in the
last 5 to seven seven years. So compute
has gotten just super powerful. We can
now house enough compute to do the
inferencing activities that help tell
the robot what to do. It's as simple as
that. So now we can create robust action
in real time uh in an environment. The
supply chain, the component pieces of
the technology have appreciably gotten
lower. When I was building humanoids at
NASA, I spent 15 years at the agency. 10
of those I was leading the humanoid
development lab and we built a a robot.
It was a lab prototype. It was Robonaut
and Valkyrie. Uh those robots were about
$2 million a piece for [snorts]
prototypes, right? When we flew it to
the space station, it got a lot more
expensive than that. But at the
prototype level, you were still talking
about a multi-million dollar humanoid.
We're able to build these now for a
couple hundred grand in quantities of
one. And that's before we start looking
at manufacturing techniques to reduce
the the price points. So, we've got the
economies of scale kicking in. We've got
the technology tipping points around
compute. Vision is basically a solved
problem. Uh if you guys remember during
the DARPA Robotics Challenge, um maybe
some of you don't because some of this
crowd looks pretty young, but when I was
there, uh you could take a camera into a
room and a few minutes later, literally
a few minutes later, you could try to
assess the objects in the room and you
might be able to understand the position
of those objects and then you might be
able to understand how to actually
approach those objects with a humanoid
manipulator. Now today you can take a
camera into a room you can identify all
the objects the pose of those objects
you can you can uh plan those
trajectories on how you would approach
and grasp and use them and you're doing
it at frame rate which is 30 times a
second. So if we went from 2 minutes to
30 times a second. So compute, vision,
componentry, and now the social side. So
humanoid robots have or embodied AI
agents depending. Uh they've invoked
some serious emotional visceral
responses. Uh but today there's much
higher social acceptance. We're now
walking around automation and and
rolling automation. There's a there's a
car there's a AMR out there delivering
coffee, right? These are just starting
to become accepted pieces in our social
architecture. So those three tipping
points have made it so that the time is
exactly right and we cannot forget the
very for uh fourth important part which
is part of the economics which is the
financeers. So now within every huge
market opportunity comes the
technologist to fill that and it has to
be financed and so we actually have an
absolute perfect storm between all three
of those things happening right now. I I
would add a fifth point to that which is
for 30 years heavy industry has not been
very receptive to technology. [snorts]
This is the first time in my career, and
I've been doing this a long, long time,
that not only is heavy industry
receptive to technology, they are
begging for it because they are at
critical choke points in being able to
not just lower the cost, but increase
production at a time that they have
labor shortages across the entire
industrial complex. So, so if if I could
add, I think the ground is fertile,
right? We've set the stage, but we still
have to deliver. And the robotics
community, let's all be very honest, has
been very long on promises and short on
delivery for a long time. But in my
view, this has been turning around
rapidly because of the aformentioned
advances that that I spoke about. And so
that doesn't preclude the realities of
manufacturing at scale, driving out the
cost, creating a machine to put in the
field reliably. AI is uh it's close.
It's not exactly all the way there there
yet, especially from the embodied level,
but it's close. It's close enough that
we can see the light at the end of the
tunnel and it's not an oncoming train.
So, I think we're we're getting there,
but but the the robotics community, we
still have to deliver and we frankly
have some lost ground to make up for.
>> Excellent. So, Sophocles, I believe, and
you and I have spoken about our mutual
opinion that we are in a
once-in-a-lifetime investment
opportunity.
uh is early movers in the phys in
investing into physical AI companies. So
for both of you, can you elaborate and
describe how you envision physical AI
will reshape the global industrial
complex over the next decade?
>> I'll start on that one. So it was
interesting from an investment
perspective. I was sitting where you all
are earlier this morning and one of the
presenters said
there are almost no public opportunities
to invest in what we're talking about
today. It's all in the private space
because it's so early. Um, in terms of
opportunity, David, just to give you a
um another metric, that 2800
10,000 football field long order that's
coming that's coming out in the next
three years, that represents about 220
billion dollars of value today that is
having is struggling. So if even you
could tap a little bit of just the
three-year production of just one
industry within the entire industrial
complex, forget energy infrastructure
rebuild, all the all the sort of u you
know the 106 trillion that needs to be
funded by 2040. The need is not a
10-year need. It's a today need. So I
think it's it's something that's
actionable now. I know I could use it
today.
>> Okay. Excellent. So, we have some time
for questions. Uh if if not or we can
continue on with our discussion.
>> Questions.
Somebody from
the first one. Is there consensus that
there needs to be a layer like a super
brain coordinating the different levels
the use case you don't want to have
robots going upstairs
you guys buy that you need a neur
we have at least two billion
How much has changer
to just change policy
or is that a crazy
>> I can take question.
>> Please do
>> or maybe I shouldn't take question two
because you want
>> I'm gonna I'm gonna take at least three
minutes and five seconds on question
one. that okay we don't have spare
humans but you know what I'm saying we
have still a high birth rate in Africa
lots and lots of people
>> I can answer I can address that from an
industry perspective do you want to go
first
>> I'll I'll I'll try to do question one uh
it is so
yes but uh it's over what time period so
it is not uh it is not
um it is not inconceivable to think that
there is a a global executive and It's
called something different by every
company because of marketing
departments, but at the end of the day,
there's a there's a global executive
which is coordinating action and we're
we're aware of it. We're trying to
address it. Um, but it's also part of
your go to market. It's also why we're
not going into the most complex
environments. Uh, the home is chaotic.
Everybody's home is different. uh
depending on how many assets of
automation you're trying to coordinate
in environments that look like that,
there's going to have to be a lot more a
little bit more world knowledge uh
understanding about what's going on. You
could however take the next incremental
step from industrial automation. So, uh
you've got robot arms on assembly lines
doing their thing. What happens with the
next step of that when you've got uh
activities that can be a little bit more
siloed that are extremely value ad that
are hard to hire for that have good
economics good use cases that you don't
have to have global neurovverse
coordination with. So our plan is we're
going to increment slowly to the more
and more complex and and more and more
asset coordination. So fleet management
is a is a big topic in the industry. So,
um, it's a it's a huge question to
unpack, but my my succinct answer is
yes, they're not wrong. Over what time
scale and over what environments?
>> Question two, am I regretting I'm
answering this? Okay. So, staying
apolitical from an ind industry
perspective. Look, I've been on the
board of one of the biggest insurance
companies in the maritime space and my
number one concern, the biggest claims,
the saddest claims are loss of life or
or or injury. Uh because these are harsh
environments. You know, you you have no
noxious gases, you have hard
environments, long work hours. So this
is where um automating those tasks where
humanoids working with humans makes um
humans safer, less claims, higher
output, which is a better social benefit
for the world. So I I think um one of
the exciting things having my background
in insurance as well is this is a really
welcome element for the human condition.
>> I want to follow that up that minefield
up with one small addition.
>> I hope I answered your question.
>> Yeah, I I guess so. I just uh you know
from from a global perspective somebody
might ask you you have still regions
with massive birth rates over population
and we're complaining oh we don't have
enough workers it begs the question
>> let me let me check
>> offline I'll talk to you
>> yeah so so Jeban's paradox is going to
apply period so the more efficient you
make an operation the more you tend to
need more of that operation so it's
going to be robots and people so what
we're trying to say is the demand is so
big right now that it's going to outpace
both those is that going to outstrip
both of those. So, it's going to be a
robots and people conversation. Um, and
there's another aspect to it where the
nature of the work that they're doing to
Sophocles's point, let's strip away a
layer of things that are killing people
and let's move people into higher
cognitive functions, training them into
higher cognitive skills, higher
educations. That's actually what you
should be focused on.
>> Thank you. and we would love to connect
with like-minded investors interested in
physical AI and humanoid robotics and
interested in this space. Thank you.
Thank you, David. [applause] Thank you,
everyone.
>> Thank you.
[music]